Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In class, one of the things
you've talked about recently
was computing surface areas
of solids of rotation.
So I have a nice problem
relating to that here.
So the circle with center
(R, 0) and radius little r--
so this is center big
R, 0, and radius little
r, which is less than big R--
is rotated around the y-axis.
And the question is,
what's the surface
area of the resulting solid?
So we have here the circle.
Its center is at
the point big R, 0,
and its radius is
little r, so this
is the equation of that circle.
And we're going to rotate
this circle around this axis.
So we're going to
spin it around.
And what you're going
to get is a donut,
or what mathematicians
call a torus.
So here's a little
schematic of it
here, with one dotted little
cross section corresponding
to this circle.
So the question is, what is
the surface area of this torus?
So why don't you
pause the video,
take a few minutes to work
this problem out yourself,
come back, and we can
work it out together.
So when we solved surface
area problems in class,
we took the curve that
we were going to rotate,
and we cut it into lots of
little pieces with length ds.
So let me draw that, just
very quickly, up here.
So we had, you took
whatever your curve was,
and you cut it into lots
of these little segments.
And then for each segment,
you rotated it around an axis.
And so if the segment has
this little length ds,
a little piece of arc
length-- so in our case,
we're going to rotate it around
the y-axis, so the length,
the area that this thing
traces out as it spins around,
is going to be this
little piece of area, dA,
which is equal to 2*pi*x*ds.
Now, this is a
little bit different
than most of the examples
Professor Jerison
did in class, because here we're
rotating around the y-axis, not
around the x-axis.
So if you rotated
around the x-axis,
what you would get is 2*pi*y*ds.
And here we get 2*pi*x*dx.
The idea of the x and the
y in this formula, this x,
it's just telling
you what the radius
is between your little segment
and the axis around which
you're rotating it.
So here this is, you know,
2*pi*x is the circumference
of this circle that it traces
out, and ds is its length,
because it's giving you a
little ribbon as it goes around.
So we have this formula,
dA equals 2*pi*x*ds.
And so in order to get the
surface area, what we do,
is we have to integrate this
over an appropriate region.
So in order to do
that, we first need,
you know, all the variables in
the integrand to be the same,
so we need to write everything
in terms of x, or everything
in terms of y, or everything
in terms of some variable
that we can integrate against.
So in our particular
case with this torus,
I think we can take
advantage of a little bit
of symmetry here, which
is that this, you know,
torus is top-bottom
symmetric, right?
As the top half of the
circle goes around,
it traces out one surface.
As the bottom half of
the circle goes around,
it traces out another surface.
But those two surfaces
have exactly the same area.
They're just mirror
images of each other,
because the circle is symmetric.
So we can just
consider the problem
of spinning the top half
of the circle around.
And so for the top
half of the circle,
we can write down
an equation for y
in terms of x, and so then
we can integrate-- you know,
that sets up a nice
integral with respect to x.
So in order to do this, well
we're going to need two things.
So we're going to need
to know what ds is.
And so you had a couple
of different formulas
for this in class.
So you had ds-- so one
easy mnemonic that I
like is to write ds equals
the square root of dx squared
plus dy squared.
So for me, this always--
I can remember this,
because it's just the
Pythagorean theorem, right?
So you have a little
dx horizontal distance,
and a little dy
vertical distance,
and so the ds is just a
hypotenuse of that triangle.
So that's how I remember this.
And so then you also have
the equivalent formula
if you factor out
a dx from here.
You know, divide through by
dx and multiply outside by dx.
You can write this as the
square root of 1 plus dy by dx
squared times, outside
the square root, dx.
So this is our little piece ds.
And OK, we have an x
in the formula already.
So ds-- so we now have
ds with a dx here.
So the only thing
we have left, is
we need to figure out
what dy/dx is in order
to put all this into the
formula, in order to integrate.
So OK.
So dy/dx.
So OK, so that means I
need y in terms of x.
Now let-- OK.
So if we're focusing only on
the top half of this torus, that
means y-- well, we can
solve this equation for y,
but when we take
the square root,
we're only taking the positive
square root, because we're only
looking at the top
half of the torus,
and then we'll just
double at the end
to account for the
bottom half as well.
So this is y equals
the square root
of-- so you solve,
you subtract x minus r
squared from both sides.
So this is little r squared
minus x minus big R squared.
So that's y.
And now you can differentiate
to get dy by dx.
All right.
So now we have to do
our chain rule right.
So we've got a 1/2 power.
So this is 1/2
times-- well, it's
going to be the inside
to the minus 1/2.
So this is over the
square root of r squared
minus x minus R quantity
squared, and now I
need to multiply by the
derivative of the inside, which
is minus 2 times x minus R. OK.
And the 2's cancel
out a little bit,
so we can rewrite this as
minus x minus R divided
by the square root
of little r squared
minus x minus R squared.
OK.
So that's dy/dx.
The square root--
that's a little ugly,
but it's OK, because we're
about to square it out again.
So all right.
So we've got dy/dx.
So now we go back,
now we can compute ds,
and then with ds, we can
go even further back,
and we can compute dA.
And once we've got
dA, to get a, we just
integrate dA over the
appropriate bounds.
So-- which we haven't
figured out yet, by the way.
We will have to talk
about that at the very,
you know, in a minute.
OK.
So we take this,
so we have dy/dx.
So from dy/dx, we
get ds is equal
to-- it's the square root of,
well, let's use this formula.
It's the square root of 1
plus, now, dy/dx squared.
OK.
So I put this in
and I square it.
So I get x minus
R squared on top.
You know, you square the
minus sign, gives you 1.
And on the bottom, we
square the square root,
so we get little r squared
minus x minus R squared, OK, dx.
Great.
Good.
So now we add these two
things together, right?
I mean, well we
want to-- I should
say-- we want to simplify
this to a usable form.
And so to put it
in a usable form,
well we're going
to manipulate it
until it looks nice, or as
nice as we could hope for.
And in this case, right.
So we can, there's an
obvious simplification,
or simplifying step,
which is we can
add this 1 into the fraction.
OK.
And so this is little r
squared minus x minus big R
squared, over little r squared
minus x minus big R squared,
and so when you add it
to x minus big R squared
over little r squared minus
x minus big R squared,
this part cancels.
And so you're left with-- OK.
And now I'm just going to pass
the square root through right
away, so this is little r over
the square root of little r
squared minus x minus
big R squared dx.
OK.
So just a little bit
of algebra there.
So this is ds.
Now, OK, so now we're going--
we want to compute surface area,
so we need dA, and dA
is 2*pi*x times ds.
So-- OK.
So that's easy to write
down now that I've got ds.
So this is dA equal to 2*pi*r*x
over r squared minus x minus
big R squared, square
root of that, dx.
All right.
This is dA.
You know, we haven't done
any calculus, actually.
Oh, I guess we took a
derivative somewhere.
We haven't done any
integration yet.
Now, to compute the surface
area, we just integrate this.
So we get to, you know, the
calculus step of this problem.
So integrate this.
But of course, you know,
I'm expecting a number out
at the end.
I'm taking a definite integral.
So I need bounds.
Well, what bounds do I need?
Well, I'm integrating
with respect to x.
So I need to integrate over
the relevant values of x.
What are the
relevant values of x?
Well, come back to
our picture over here.
We have this circle.
Its center is at x
equals R, y equals 0.
And it has radius little r.
So, you know, the
relevant values of x
are just from the leftmost
point of the circle
to the rightmost
point of the circle.
And so this leftmost
point is just-- well,
the radius is
little r, so this is
big R minus-- x equals
big R minus little r,
and the rightmost point is x
equals big R plus little r.
So the bounds-- so I'm going
to go up here-- so I have area
is what I get when
I integrate dA.
And I want to integrate it from
x equals big R minus little
r to big R plus little
r, and dA is this thing
I found, just a moment ago.
So this is-- well, OK.
So 2*pi little r is a constant.
I'm just going to factor
that out in front.
So this is 2*pi little r times
x over the square root of little
r squared minus big R minus--
sorry-- x minus big R squared.
That's all under
the square root.
ds.
OK.
So now we have to figure out
how to integrate this thing.
Right?
So this is a little ugly.
It's not horrible, though.
Right?
So down here we have
something that's
really reminiscent of one of
these trig integral things
we've done.
Right?
We've got a square root
of a something squared
minus a something else squared.
So that, reminds, you
know, what does that
remind, maybe some
sine substitution.
Something like that.
There's some there's some
trig substitution waiting
to happen here.
But, so OK.
We could sort of shoot to do
it all in one substitution.
I like, my life
always feels simpler
when I do one little
substitution at a time.
And so one little
substitution I could do
is to simplify this
x minus r thing.
I could just shift this by r.
So I'm just going to do a
little linear substitution.
I'm going to do u
equals x minus big R,
or I'm going to want to
substitute the other way,
so that's the same thing as
saying x equals u plus big R.
And so du equals dx.
This is a simple
little substitution.
And I'm going to have
to move the bounds,
so when x is big R minus little
r, then u is minus little r,
and this top bound here, u is
going to be equal to little r.
Positive little r.
So let me just make
that substitution.
So area is 2 pi little
r, integral from
minus little r to plus little r.
So x is u plus big
R divided by, now
this thing becomes square root
of little r squared minus u
squared du.
OK, all right.
So now-- this is really kind
of two separate pieces, right,
for purposes of
difficulty of integrating.
There's the u over the
square root of r squared
minus u squared
piece, and there's
the big R over the
square root of r
squared minus u squared piece.
So let's think about
them separately.
So for this first piece,
the u over the square root
of little r squared
minus u squared,
this is something
you can integrate.
This is a-- you don't need a
trig substitution to do that.
But it's actually-- you don't
need to do any work to do that.
Because that function u
divided by square root
of little r squared
minus u squared,
that's an odd function.
Right?
This part, the denominator
is even, u is odd,
and we're integrating
over an interval that's
symmetric around the origin.
So when we integrate this u
divided by this denominator
part between u from minus r to
r, that's just going to give 0.
So I can forget
about that entirely.
So this is nice.
And then I'll have
a constant here,
so I'm going to factor
that out as well.
So I get 2 pi little
r big R, integral
from minus r to r of du over the
square root of little r squared
minus u squared.
OK.
Good.
So far, so good.
So we've got this
nice simplified
form for the integral.
So now this is screaming
out trig substitution to me.
Right?
There's nothing else I can do.
So there's sort of two
things you could do.
One is you could recognize
this as an integral related
to arcsine, just because
you remember that.
The other is, you have this r
squared minus u squared thing.
And so r squared
minus u squared, that
needs a trig substitution
of some sort,
and the relevant trig
substitution that you
would want to do,
is you would want
to set u equal to r sine t.
Why?
Because then down here we'll
have r squared minus r squared
sine t, or if you factor out
the little r, that's just 1
minus sine squared t,
which is cosine squared t,
and then you take a square root,
and you're all good, right?
Square root of cosine squared t.
OK.
So we find this
trig substitution.
So if we do u equals
r sine t, that's good.
So du, then, is r
cosine t dt, and I
need to change the bounds, so
minus u is equal to minus r
when sine of t is
equal to minus 1.
So that's at minus pi over 2.
And u is equal to r when
sine of t is equal to 1.
So that's a pi over 2.
So this is equal to 2 pi
little r big R integral
from minus pi over 2 to
pi over 2 of r cosine t dt
divided by-- OK.
So then down here, we
have the square root
of r squared minus r
squared sine squared t.
And as we said, so r squared
minus r squared sine squared t,
this is r squared
cosine squared t.
And then you take a square root,
and you just get r cosine t.
And so r cosine t
cancels r cosine t.
So the integrand here
is actually 1, or 1 dt.
So that's really
easy to integrate.
You integrate a constant,
you just get-- well,
the constant times the
length of the integral.
So this is equal to 2*pi*r*R
times the constant is 1,
times the length of the
integral, which is another pi,
times pi.
OK.
So this is equal to 2 pi squared
little r big R. But remember,
so far we've only
computed-- this is just
the top half of the torus, is
all we've ever talked about.
So we want to get the whole
torus, you just double this.
So you double this, and you
get the area of the whole torus
is 4 pi squared little r big
R, which is a nice formula.
So quickly, just to
summarize what we've done.
Standard setup.
Here we did it, we're rotating
around the y-axis instead
of the x-axis.
So this formula for
dA looks a little bit
different than what you
saw in class, mostly.
But the thing to remember
is just that what goes here
is the radius that this,
that your little segment is
traveling.
And this is the circumference
that it's traveling,
and so this is the area
of that little ribbon
that it traces out.
So dA-- OK.
And then we just did, you
know, the sort of usual thing.
For your formula,
you need-- you know,
you remember the formula for ds.
Then you needed to find this
derivative and plug it in.
And so after you've done all
that preparatory work then
you have your integrand set up.
And once you set
up your integrand,
you do whatever integration
tools you can to hit it with.
So in our case, that was
simplifying substitution,
and then a nice observation that
we used here to simplify this,
that this part was odd.
I mean, you could've-- you
didn't need that observation.
You could have done the
problem perfectly well
with another substitution there
to kill off that first part.
And then, OK, and then
a trig substitution,
remembering that
this is an arcsine,
or related to an arcsine,
to finish it off.
And is there anything
else I want to say?
I think that's-- oh, yes.
There's one other
thing I wanted to say,
which is that we could have
done this slightly differently.
Which is, here we solved for
y explicitly in terms of x.
And it would have been
possible to carry this
through using implicit
differentiation instead.
It would have
actually simplified--
I would have had to write
this square root of little r
squared minus x minus big R
quantity squared fewer times
if I'd done implicit
differentiation, starting
from this implicit
equation relating x and y.
You have to be a
little careful there,
whether you're doing the whole
circle all at once, or just
the top half or the bottom half.
But you could do it with
implicit differentiation
instead, and maybe save
yourself a little bit
of messy-looking arithmetic.
So I think I'll end there.